very happy today to uh welcome dean
uh to come talk to us and give us a
workshop tutorial series on uh dvc which
i believe is a
version control for uh data science
models and uh data sets
um
dean is the ceo and co-founder of
dagshub i believe we're we've already
had
another talk about another dexa person
uh talking about how they've actually
contributed and they've made
a lot of interesting interactive stuff
to do with the jupiter notebooks so
we're super happy uh to have dean um
again ceo of daxon to come and talk to
us about this
thank you uh i had it up to you
awesome thank you for the introduction
conrad um it's really a pleasure to be
here and take part in this uh awesome
conference it's also really good to see
so many people
join into the call so i'm guessing
you're curious about uh data versioning
practices and i'll i hope i'll address
all of your uh sort of uh questions and
and things that you're interested in
during this uh uh talk as i mentioned uh
if you joined uh before this or after
this rather uh if you have any question
then feel free to stop uh stop me in the
middle and ask uh i might say that i'll
address those later but you can also ask
via your own voice or type it in the
chat and i'll try to address it
as i go along so the title of my talk is
who moved my data and this is going to
be a data version control showcase so
the overarching uh topics that we will
address are
at a high level why reproducibility and
data version control sort of uh matter
for your day-to-day lives uh we'll show
we'll discuss an overview of dbc um uh
so sort of basic operating principles um
and how that sort of looks and feels and
then we will crack open the hood and
look underneath and understand the basic
dbc operating principles
we'll discuss working with dvc remotes
which basically
sort of expands the capability of data
versioning into
teamwork
if you are familiar with the term data
centric ai which is now sort of growing
in popularity this is one tool to be
more data centric we'll then discuss
using dbc to ensure reproducibility of
your data science pipelines um and then
like everything no one is perfect and no
tool is perfect so we'll discuss why and
when you should use dbc whether it's
pros and cons um and then finally we'll
also
just sort of review a tool called fds or
fast data science which combines dbc and
git into one
and so
that is going to be sort of the i'm
going to talk about all of these topics
and then we'll have a hands-on demo
which is going to be a notebook that
i'll share with you during this call so
you can open and sort of follow along
where we'll review those things and and
sort of uh practice what we preach so
it's not just a theoretical and high
level
um so that's that's it and let's get
started
uh so a few words about me and my
background
it's a combination of physics machine
learning and computer science
i am
really passionate about building tools
for that help machine learning teams
work together and i'm even more
passionate about the role that open
source has to play in the world of
machine learning but in general i'm a
strong believer in open source
software i am also the co-founder of
dagsub where we are building a sort of
github for machine learning we're taking
amazing and popular open source tools
for ml and sort of combining them into a
platform that makes them easier and more
convenient to use as well as adding
abilities and workflows needed to work
with them as a team and then i'm also
the host of the mlaps podcast where i
speak with industry
experts about bringing machine learning
into the real world and this is sort of
also to address the
necessary question of why should you
listen to me um sort of one of the tools
that we're integrating closely with in
dags of is dbc so i'm very familiar with
the tool and its internals
but on the other hand i have had the
chance to review and use many other
tools in the industry and so i have a
broad perspective on tooling in the ml
market in my opinion and then i also
welcome you to follow me on twitter or
on linkedin um
where we're sort of i share more about
all of these topics that i just
mentioned
cool
so sort of a motivation um i don't know
if if everyone here remembers this
statistic this is kind of a
semi-regurgitated uh
fact which is not necessarily true about
the data science world um this was
probably true uh two years ago or closer
to true two years ago but people like to
say that 87 percent of data science
projects never make it to production
um
but
i would argue that this is no longer the
case and we sort of ran this poll with
over 2 000 votes um from industry
professionals and we see that over 80 of
teams already have models in production
and 25
uh of them have more than 10 models in
production and so that means that if
you're listening to this talk um and
you're working as part of a data science
team your team probably has a model in
production already and if it doesn't it
will probably have one in a not too
distant future and so if a few years ago
everyone was looking at google and
amazon and facebook and saying like i
want what they have with respect to the
data science uh
uh sort of tooling and workflows today
even small startups even traditional
organizations that have data science
teams are already getting to production
and that means um
and that means that basically you sort
of understand that many aspects of real
data science and machine learning work
starts when you start when you deploy
that first
model into your production so
at that scale things tend to look a bit
different from the proof of concept
stage
and so holding together things with duct
tape might have gone fine at that point
but it's no longer uh uh sort of uh
productive to do that when you're
deploying your tenth model into
production so laszlo hey um commented
that the 87 was uh was uh bs statistic
originally and i tend to agree so i
don't like that statistic but i would
say that sort of the overwhelming uh um
vibe that you would get a year and a
half ago as sort of an ml practitioner
is that most organizations are sort of
in the proof of concept stage so they
have something they're not sure how to
get it to production um and and so
what i'm saying is basically that there
has been a shift and so now um
if if i had to choose sort of a fit
something which is a major thing that's
holding the field back is that uh we
don't have sort of a standard uh
uh workflow and so
uh you you want to sort of automate
the process of iterating on machine
learning models so not just automating
your training pipeline uh and your
deployment process but also the
iteration itself and so you need
flexible tools to solve these challenges
and i would argue and this is basically
the main argument
that is backing sort of reproducibility
and data version control that
reproducibility is one of the main
challenges that we have to deal with in
order to get to this promised land of a
standard workflow
and so
basically what we're missing today is we
want to connect to the existing
production setups
so that we can have a real impact on the
organization that you that we're in and
then if your machine learning lives on a
separate planet everything is going to
be very slow and very painful the second
thing is everyone is talking about
hashtag data centric ai but in practice
many teams don't have uh proper access
to their data and it's treated as a
second class citizen in in many cases so
i've spoken with data scientists in the
last two weeks that basically said that
they want to be data-centric but they
have to talk to five different people in
their organization just to play around
with their data in a context which is
not an automated pipeline and that
doesn't make sense and finally we're
sort of disconnected from each other so
obviously more models in in production
means growing your team um but if the
processes that make it possible to grow
your team are vague or broken then
you're going to have a bad time
so if we are in misattributed statistics
and quotes i'll take uh alberts
einstein's albert einstein's misquoted
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over and expecting different results
so einstein didn't really say this i'll
let you
give you a moment to let that sink in um
but the gist of this sentence is
something that i very much agree with
which is the ability to
rerun a project and get the same results
is at the base of standardization um and
in that context you sort of really want
to get the same result when you're
re-running your project's code
so you want to work in a sane way um and
and and so and so this is sort of a
prerequisite to preserve your sanity
while working on machine learning then
the increase in complexity
requires better handling and engineering
otherwise things will break
more often and maintaining
reproducibility will make it easier to
debug and audit your own work
it is also a prerequisite for teamwork
as i mentioned in the sense that it
helps remove single points of failure in
the system and it makes it so that not
every task is a cold start meaning you
don't if you have a new task now um
then you don't have to start as if this
was a new project that you can actually
pick up where someone left off whether
it's you in the past or someone else on
your team
um and then finally
in many ways the
the best way to treat data as a first
class citizen means treating it the same
way we treat our code
so it logically follows that we should
version our data with the asterisks that
we're going to discuss
later
um and so
sorry
yeah the videos are disappearing um so
the good news is that we don't have to
start from scratch um a lot of time has
been spent and a lot of mental blood has
been spilled to produce tools that
manage code workflows uh do version code
version control and then define the best
practice the best practices within the
realm of software engineering um and
this is not to say that we should accept
everything coming from software
engineering as the word of god um but as
a rule of thumb reinventing the wheel is
a strong sign that we might have taken a
wrong turn and so usually if you find
yourself saying yeah we should rebuild
everything from scratch then it's it's
probably sort of a good idea to check
whether or not there are good solutions
for that um
for that issue sort of uh beforehand um
and so and finally sort of git
specifically and version control in
general were arguably the start of the
solution for complexity in software
engineering and so an entire world of
git ops ci cd infrastructure and as code
were slowly built on top of that
enabling sort of automations and
relatively speedy iteration process and
teamwork at scale
um so now let's dive into
uh into the the details so how does data
version control fit into this whole
thing and i guess before that one side
note in this entire talk when i say data
versioning i mean data and artifacts and
that means uh intermediate results so if
you're pre-processing your data your raw
data then the intermediate results are
also considered data for the purpose of
this talk but also models uh are
something that you version so in some
cases i'll say model versioning
explicitly but even when i say data
visioning i mean this in in the broader
sense of like the artifacts and the data
that that we have in our process
and sort of the main mental model that i
propose is relatively straightforward
which is treat your data as if it as if
it was source code or a part of your
source code stop thinking about version
control only for code i.e text documents
that are sort of limited in size and
amount and even if you don't change
anything like you disagree that gbc is a
good tool you don't want to use it that
or or maybe it's not suitable for your
use case that's okay but starting to
think about data as part of your source
code is going to educate the decision
making process you you you do in the
future and i think that's going to be
useful
um and so once you do that the next
shift is sort of starting to think about
combining code data models
configurations metrics all in one
version and that is also the dvc
approach whether formally or under the
hood and and so in other words every
experiment is a commit and i think that
that is good for a lot of use cases it
does not fit all of them um and so i'll
try to address this as well and if i
forget then please uh remind me
so what is dbc oh sorry this is the
animation um so what is dvc dbc is short
for data version control
it is a
command line tool for data science and
machine learning version control and
reproducibility and dvc also now offers
some basic experiment tracking
capabilities but i don't think that
that's sort of the their core focus and
and so we won't focus on those
capabilities in this talk we're going to
focus on again uh versioning and uh
reproducibility and i guess maybe this
is a good time before i dive into the
technical details uh any questions so
far
i'll take a sip of water
okay cool
so
um the first objection that you might
have to everything that i just said is
why can't i just use git and get lfs uh
for this task and so forget the question
is pretty straightforward it's just not
good at handling large files and
especially binaries it's just it's not
it's not built for that um get lfs is a
bit more nuanced it has its limitations
as well but i would argue that first and
foremost it's not optimized for for data
science work it doesn't have the data
scientists as the first class uh um sort
of user of the tool and it misses some
clear
preferences that developers and data
scientists have the simplest example of
this is that
the git lfs requires that you work with
a dedicated git lfs server instead of
working with the cloud storage options
that are widely used
and i would argue that dbc's version
control capabilities for data are sort
of like a better version of git lfs this
might be a hot take i know that there
are a lot of people that love git lfs uh
but again you're not here to listen to
things that you already know and i think
that uh uh really we can see this in
sort of the usage
of these different tools
so
dvc um is basically at a high level a
tool that extends
git sort of seamlessly and i emphasize
extends because dbc relies on git
for managing the the versions and and
we'll see how that works in a moment so
you can track all of your large files
whether it's uh data models artifacts
even metrics and this flexibility also
means that creating something like a
model registry which is now also a term
that like a capability that a lot of
teams and data scientists want um has
the same flow as tracking a data set and
so it's really versatile
reproducibility is built in especially
specifically with bbc's pipeline feature
uh which we'll cover and it's built to
handle large files and use the common
remote storages without any sort of
dedicated servers in the middle and of
course it's open source um so a lot of
awesomeness here and now we get to the
heart of things so how does dvc uh work
and before we look under the hood i want
to give an example at a high level of
the uh of the the sort of operating
principles of dbc so let's say we have
our uh sort of local uh uh file system
we have our get remote and our dvc uh oh
sorry our git cache and our dbc cache
and this can also be our git remote and
our dvc remote i'll talk about the
differences
but let's say we have this really really
large file it contains the secrets of
the universe and we want to track it and
so we're going to use dbc to track that
uh because that's what it's optimized
for and so what we're going to do is
we're going to run a command which is
dvc add we'll i'll show you what that
does
again under the hood in a moment but
what that's going to do is it's going to
put the
large file in the dvc cache and it's
going to create two small text files one
of them is a git ignore so if that's
already created it's going to add a line
to the git ignore and the other is a
file with the same name with an
additional extension of dot dbc and this
is a simple text file which is a pointer
to the data file that it is that resides
within the ddc cache and then both of
these are going to be
um here in my git cache and also in my
file system itself
so both of these are referring to
version a so now let's see what happens
when i change the versions so let's say
i now modified my universe.txt i added
more secrets of the universe to it and
so now this is the version b of of that
file but as you noticed i haven't done
anything with respect to dbc or git so
both of those caches don't have any
mention of this version b yet and so
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
do dvc add to that
new file with the same name and so
what's going to happen is again it's
going to be copied into
our dvc cache and the local files that
are now that are managed by git are
going to be modified to reflect this new
version um
and then i'm going to do a git
commit or git add in a git commit and
then i'll have my git cache include the
new version of these pointer files and
the git ignore and so we can do that
again with file version c and then dbc
add so it modifies this again and it
goes back to the uh git cache so now we
have all three versions in both caches
and let's say we want to revert like
let's say version c wasn't good for us
and we want to go back to a different
version so how do we do that we first
want to revert the version of the
pointer file so what we're going to do
is we're going to do if this is in the
local
cache we're going to do git checkout to
the specific version that we wanted
and then or we can do uh git reset
as well and that both of those options
could work um and then let's say we
again we want to revert to version a so
we're going to do that and then the next
thing that happens is the pointer files
will now reflect version 8 but still
version the the file itself is in
version c so in order to
sort of synchronize the the dbc file we
need to run a dvc command which is
either dbc checkout
or if it's not in the local cache we
need to pull it from the remote okay and
then once we do that then uh uh we take
the uh sort of version a from here and
put it inside of the the file system and
so
basically what would happen in this case
is for from the user's point of view
they they sort of see you sort of see
magic right because the the file name
remains the same and then the underlying
contents are changed but what's
happening sort of under the hood is is
exactly what i just showed um and so
alina is asking whether or not it's
required to run dbc push after adding a
new version of the file so it depends
basically and we'll also show an example
of this when we get to the hands-on part
but basically when you do dvc add that
file is going to be put in the dbc cache
and sort of a nuance here which i i'll
mention later again but the nuance here
is that dbc has a bunch of optimizations
for different file systems so it knows
not it knows if you if your file system
supports this it will not do redundant
copies of the file but it will actually
move the file into the cache and then
create a link in your local system so
that it looks as if there's a copy but
it will only copy it when you modify
stuff so that's pretty cool but but to
answer your question if you modify the
um the the file and you do dbc add or if
it's a pipeline you do dvc commit then
those files will then be copied into
your local cache and so you don't need
to push them unless you want to share it
with someone else or you want to delete
it from your local system which is very
a very reasonable use case because um
like even for me personally i do a bunch
of projects on my local laptop
eventually even if you're working with
not so huge data sets like two gigabytes
uh after like 20 versions maybe uh your
laptop runs out out of a space or 20
versus 20 projects and so you'd want to
push that to a storage that
probably limits you less and then you
will pull it back so hopefully that
answers the question um but basically
okay so going back to uh sort of the the
flow basically what this means is that
reproducing all the elements of an
experiment um is as simple as doing git
checkout plus the dbc checkout which you
can also unify like dbc has a bunch of
uh
like git hooks that you can use and also
i'll show you how to do that with fds so
that it's one command for both but the
idea is like with one command you can
get a copy of your entire uh sort of a
snapshot of your project
as it was when you committed it which is
pretty useful uh even before we're
talking about pipelines so irwin is
asking is it possible to keep the data
in the cloud when selecting it so not to
have the data local but load the correct
data version from the cloud into memory
so the answer is yes that is an advanced
use case i'll discuss it briefly uh
later um
but yeah but usually if this is the use
case that you think you need um then you
should probably
like make sure that you're correct
because in many cases there is a simpler
solution
but yes dvc supports remote working file
systems that's how that's the name of
what you're describing and i'll touch
upon that a bit later
so cool um we understand how dbc works
at a high level and now let's uh look
under the hood of what's of what's going
on um but but again to summarize so it's
kind of like it it uses a hash table for
a cache and in a later uh part of this
talk we'll show that you can push and
pull parts of this cache to uh remotes
to remote storage
okay so this is an example uh uh project
that i have um and we'll show a more
sophisticated example in the hands-on
part but i think this shows sort of the
capabilities of dvc pretty
straightforwardly and so here i have a
like a project tree um i'm not showing
hidden files so basically i have a data
folder and under that i have a raw.csv i
have a metrics.csv a models folder with
some model that i created and some code
which runs something in this case
it basically creates a model and so
let's say i want to track the data file
with dvc so the command i would use is
dbc add data
raw.csv
and then dbc will give me this output
and and so it will tell me that it has
been added and then it even tells me
which command i should run uh with git
in order to track the changes uh uh that
i just made to the project but what
actually happens under the hood so i
mentioned this sort of at the high at a
high level so first the the first thing
you're going to notice that changes is i
i have a new file added to this uh uh
project just
raw.csv.dbc i also have a new git ignore
file which which you can't see here
but basically
if i do
uh cat data raw.csv.bc
and i want to see the contents of this
file what i'll see is i have an md5 hash
okay and basically what dvc did here is
it ran a hashing algorithm over the
original file and it got this unique
identifier which is version specific so
any change to that file will will
mean that the hash of that file will be
different to the one that dbc calculated
it also provides a bit of metadata
specifically the size of this so you can
see that because this was a demo this is
a very small this is the size and bytes
by the way it's a very small file and
the path of this of the original file
and the path is always relative to where
the dbc file exists so in this case the
dbc file is in the same folder as the
csv so it's telling me that it's the
same place just for raw.csv
the next thing that we want to look at
is we would look inside the dbc cache
which is located in dot dbc
and what we can see there is we have
this interesting folder structure where
the
folder name is the first two characters
in that hash
and inside that folder we have a file
that has no extension um and that file
name is the rest of the characters of
that hash okay so this is maybe the the
first uh
nuanced point so i'll repeat that dvc
calculated this hash
and then it copied that hash into the
dvc cache and it stores it in a
structure where the first two letters of
that hash are the file name and the the
rest of the uh hash is the folder is the
file sorry the the first two letters is
the folder name and the rest of the hash
is the file name okay and so
uh if we were to uh read this file uh
assuming that we know that this is the
type of file that it is then we would
see the same content okay
um and then um and then the last file
that has been added is again the the git
ignore file and when you
peer into that you can see that raw.csv
was added there and that makes sense
because we don't want we don't want git
to track that file because dbc is not
tracking it
um so jack asks if this is if it is a
good practice to have the dvc file in
the same directory as the file
um i would i i don't know if i have a
strong opinion on that the way that dbc
operates is that it will put the
dvc file in the same uh
folder that you ran the uh the ad for so
dvc also supports adding uh folders and
then if we would do dbc add data then we
would have in the root folder of the
project the data.dbc that is managing
the entire folder and because i told it
to add a file which exists within the
data folder it puts the dbc file there
so that's the default behavior i guess i
don't i don't know if there's a strong
preference here
if that makes sense
okay cool so hopefully this part was
clear
um
basically uh just to sort of again
review what we've saw what we've seen
dvc has uh sort of um has
this process where it can add the file
to your cache it creates a bunch of text
files that are tracked by git and point
to the correct version and so
um some of the nice things that you get
with dbc uh by this point like some of
the super powers that you've already
gained here is that dbc has built-in
optimizations for large folders so it
natively supports workflows around for
example unstructured data sets
it also does uh file level deduplication
which is like git and that means that if
you have a folder of 1000 images and you
change only one image then dvc is not
going to duplicate all the 1000 images
it's going to duplicate just the one
that has been changed in the cache
but on the other hand
if you have a table which is five
gigabytes and you change one row of that
table that entire table will be
duplicated because it's it's the same
file okay
and finally you have a local cache which
is very useful for quick checkout um so
it means that if you have a data version
that you've accessed in the past uh they
are they will be saved nearby and make
it easy for you and fast to sort of uh
check them out without needing to
download them from anywhere and this
does mean that you need to be aware of
your cash and garbage collected as
needed
otherwise it might
grow very very very quickly
um and
so so uh yang is asking if it is a
better practice to split data into
smaller files and the short answer is
yes if your workflow supports that um so
so i think the technical term here is
sharding um and i think that the uh guys
at dbc are possibly working on
integrating that as sort of a
first-class uh use case uh but currently
yes if you can split if you have if
you're working with tabular data and you
can split that data in in a way that
makes sense then that would be very
useful uh whereas for unstructured data
again like image data sets and stuff
like that then dvc just works out of the
box you could just do dvc add data set
and if that's a folder with the images
and it would work
cool so we have a few super powers um i
might just uh uh pick up the pace a bit
so we have enough time to go over
everything um so we have a few
superpowers gained one of them is a sort
of
time travel so we have now a time
machine that lets us uh that doesn't
only encompass one part of our project
just the code but actually the entire
context so something bad happens we can
easily revert to the project before the
issue is introduced and this will also
speed up debugging um so so it's also
useful for for disaster recovery um but
then the next question might be okay but
i have a team of four people
and i want to take care of sort of the
flows that are involved when you have
more than one person working on a
project uh
so how can we use our newly gained
powers to improve the team oriented
activities that that sort of we'd like
to happen and so we'll talk about task
splitting a bit later uh but starting
with onboarding and handoffs uh the next
logical step is remotes so if git
remotes is what enables a new developer
joining a software team to get started
with the codebase dbc remotes enable
sort of the same experience for a new
data data scientist um and so dvc
remotes are similar to get remotes they
will let you define dc lets you define
multiple remotes which is useful for
some use cases
it's important to note that due to the
differences in this workflow uh in the
workflow the remotes are separate from
the get remote used except for the case
of dagsub where they sort of exist
alongside each other and this is mostly
an advantage because it means you aren't
tied to your git provider so if you can
connect the data storage uh to any of
the cloud providers or whichever storage
solution you use but it does mean that
you need to pay attention to which files
are pushed to get and which files are
pushed to your dvc remote
now once you define a dvc remote you can
push parts of the hash table or the
cache to that remote and all of this is
done under the hood with the libraries
of these object storages so that means
that you add minimal overhead on top of
these very efficient libraries when you
use them
and that also means that dvc doesn't
need dedicated servers and it's built to
handle really large files and folders
like data sets and also there is very
broad support for different types of
remotes
so
how does the remote workflow look like
you basically have one command which is
similar to the get remote ad
action that you do
with the difference that you need to
also manage authentication so
authentication uh varies by uh the type
of remote that you're using but in the
simplest case which is which is uh sort
of http or the dags of remotes you
basically add three lines of code to
your project and then you are good to go
uh and then in order to push data you
just do dvc push minus r um origin or
the name of the the remote so in this
case i called my remote origin and and
you're off to the races um and so
under the hood dbc will review the
hashes of the files
within the remote and compare them to
what you have in your local cache it
will locate the relevant files that are
that sort of comply with two things
first they need to be in your current
workspace um so files that aren't in the
workspace are not going to be pushed by
default
um
and uh sort of are missing from the
remote hash table and then it's going to
push them and only them to the remote so
what that means is that if you push
after every commit your local and remote
hashes hash tables should be the same
that makes them available for the rest
of your team
um
so the basic workflow is basically uh um
sort of
uh
sharing data and trained models are is
super easy uh and you just do it with a
dvc push and then a dvc pull um and and
you can also recycle pre-processed data
which is a nice uh basic use case so if
i ran a pre-processing step uh that took
three hours um and i don't want you to
run it as well i can push the result to
our dvc storage you can pull it and it's
as if you uh ran it yourself um so
that's pretty convenient especially have
if you have a setup where you have maybe
a training server which is stronger than
your local computer but then you do want
to do some pre post processing or
visualization locally um so both of
these are covered basically by the flow
of dbc push and dbc pull
but there are also some more advanced
use cases so one of those use cases is
data and model registries and i
mentioned this briefly before but uh
this is a use case where uh if you
haven't so so the idea of this use case
is basically that you have an entire
repository which is dedicated to
tracking a single type of artifact so
you either have a repository that has
like data sets with an update uh an
updating version or maybe you you push
your trained models to another model
repository and then you update those
versions as well and so
that is then that can then be consumed
by multiple teams or projects so if you
have this complicated pipelines and
multiple teams are responsible for
different parts and this also is
starting to address the task splitting
aspects um then you can have one person
working on this reprocessing step and
generating new versions and treating it
as if it was a package um and then other
teams can actually use dvc import
um and and then import that uh data set
or model into their uh into their system
um and so that is very uh that is a very
useful
use case for for many teams um and i'll
share later a blog post that we wrote
about this if you're uh interested in
diving deeper
um and then also
um we talked about remote working file
systems or someone here asked um and
uh er when asked about this so dvc can
also enable you to extend your local
workspace and this can be relevant when
you're working with for example huge
files that don't fit locally
we won't go into the finer details here
since this is a more advanced use case
but the gist of it is that you can
define a remote with a relative path
um and so that it
such that it exists on your cloud
storage and a version of it or not a
version but uh a copy of this exists for
each participant so basically you're
extending your local working file system
to your cloud and this will let you add
files uh to dbc directly from cloud to
cloud without it touching your local
system
and this is especially useful if you're
doing remote processing or if you want
to read process data by batches and i
don't think i put the link in this uh
talk but feel free to reach out to me
out afterwards i also have an example
project with this
if this is uh relevant for you guys
okay so we talked about um
let's see if there were any questions
philip says
how can you run a recursive command
using dvc
um
okay so basically uh that answer the
answer to that question is is separated
into two you can first do dvc add minus
r which is recursive and what that will
do is if you uh input a folder with that
it will basically add the entire
contents of the folder to dbc file by
file so it doesn't use the optimization
that dbc has um uh for uh for directory
so this is not recommended unless you're
sure that this is what you need
um and then the
git add minus a experience uh and again
combining that with with dvc is
something i'll show with fast data
science but that's something that we
developed where uh it's open source as
well but the idea is that we identify
files that might that you might want to
put in in dvc and those that might one
might want to put in and get and sort of
ask you where you want to put each um so
that's uh one thing and um
yeah so there's also okay so i see
someone is also answering uh for this
awesome so let's continue so you might
notice uh at this point uh that
reproducibility isn't perfectly
addressed by saving the versions of
artifacts so we've made big strides
towards it but we aren't there just yet
um and so
at this point you might argue something
like uh what about managing
configurations what about the packages
and the environments that i'm using they
aren't covered yet too but in that case
i would argue that all of those might be
maintained as text files or artifacts um
and and they would be versioned with
either git or dbc so i'm not talking
about that caveat the caveat that i'm
talking about is um and let's look at a
problem example so going to basic math
because a good uh uh data talk has to
have a bit of math in it right uh so
let's say we have two processing steps
in in our project and each of them
receives some input and performs a very
basic mathematical function on it now if
we're running uh
function one then function two we're
going to get x plus one squared but if
we run version uh
function two and then function one we're
going to get x squared plus one and in
most cases those results are not equal
so first check on math um and that's
sort of
some sort of proof in theory that
reproducibility might be more
challenging than just managing the
artifacts
um
but why should i care about this in real
life and the answer to that is in my
opinion that many things can go wrong
and ensuring reproducibility means it's
easier to pinpoint the issues so you can
look at where your sort of pipeline is
breaking apart and focus there instead
of having to go over everything to find
issues it also shortens the time to
onboarding handoff and all of those
other uh sort of activities by orders of
magnitude because you don't need to sort
of start
from scratch and assume that things are
working
but you can actually see them work and
and sort of apply changes and then run
only those changes which is pretty
awesome
and then finally you can be sure that
you're comparing apples to apples which
i think every data scientist realize how
important that is when you think the two
models are sort of you just change a few
parameters but then you realize that you
train them on completely different data
sets um and that and and that's why sort
of the um
the uh performance is completely
different so what i would like you to
take away from this is that you should
track your pipeline um and the best way
to do that uh is with uh dags uh so
we're obviously biased but i hope
everyone here likes tags as well um and
so
basically
uh dags let you define
dependencies outputs and commands
for the different
sort of
machine learning pipeline stages that
you have
they are basically necessary for
ensuring reproducibility so even if you
don't define a dag officially the order
of it by which things run in your
pipeline is is an integral part of
making sure you get the same results um
and this shouldn't be scary so uh um
the the simplest way to define a dag is
just a yaml file and i'll show an
example of that there are many ways to
define a tag but but it's really
it can be human readable it could be
very friendly and dbc lets you define uh
define them
and then you also get a bonus of
versioning all the dependencies and
outputs which is pretty awesome
um
so
basically
the there are multiple ways to define a
dag stage in dbc one of them is to use
the dbc run command which receives
inputs
which receives sort of the inputs or the
dependencies with the minus d flag so
you can see in my case i have the data
raw csv and also the code is a
dependency for this stage the output is
the model and then i also have an output
which is the metric and i gave the stage
a name that's a minus n flag and uh
finally i give it the command that it
should run and we can also define the
stage without running it so in this case
if i just use this command like this dbc
will define that stage and run the
command as well
sorry but we can also use the minus
minus so no exec flag when we do this
and then dvc will only define the stage
uh uh on in the yaml without running it
and so once we run this command what
we're going to get is two new files so
the dbc.yaml which is basically super
human readable it has stages the name of
the stage the command that's being run
the dependencies which is like a list
the outputs which is also a list and in
this case we also have metrics which is
just a special type of output um and so
what we're using here is cache false
which basically means
by default dbc assumes that every output
of a stage is something that dvc should
track so if you want it not to track a
file or in other words for to have git
track it then you just need to make sure
that it has cache uh false within the
yaml and then the other uh uh thing that
you we're going to see is the dbc
dot lock file um
and so what we're seeing we're going to
see in there is basically a similar
structure
um but in addition each of these files
has the md5 so you the unique hash uh
and a bit more metadata so the size of
the file um
and and that's sort of what dvc uses to
make sure which files have changed
so with dags we can visualize this um
and this is just a bit more intuitive to
explain what's going on here so you can
see that basically this command is sort
of the essence of the stage and if you
actually expand this i'll show this
later
you can see that command within this tag
you can see that the data is sort of the
input here
and then you have the code which is
running here which is sort of an input
as well the metrics are here and finally
the output model is here as well so you
can sort of see the equivalent between
the text file and the visualization
which is obviously more convenient but
it's basically the same uh information
cool so we're almost at the end and
getting to the hands-on part so
bonuses from dbc dags in addition to
sort of the reproducibility you get the
added benefits that execution might be
painful in many cases um and so you
don't want to run what you what you
haven't changed and so for example
training a model in some cases
pre-processing might be very compute or
time intensive um and and that might and
this is a trade-off so it depends on the
price you pay for this processing versus
the price you pay for storage but in
cases where the processing it costs more
than the storage then you can basically
ddc conversion the the outputs and then
check what has basically check what has
changed and only run the things uh uh
that that are necessary to reproduce the
end result
um and finally you can automate this
entire process you can define very
complex pipelines and then just use gvc
repro to rerun the entire thing
which is pretty awesome and so to
conclude all of this part uh sorry did
someone say something
okay um so to conclude this part uh
basically we're producing a result you
with uh git checkout sort of gets you
the files and then you can verify that
it runs from start to finish with dvc
repro which again is super useful um
especially in sort of team use cases
okay so uh pros and cons i see that
there's a question i'll address it in a
moment i'll just finish with the
presentation so we can get to the
hands-on part
so pros and cons why and when to use dbc
uh first
we're strong believers or i'm a strong
believer that you shouldn't use tools
for the sake of tools um the you want to
know which problem you're trying to
solve and having a hammer shouldn't make
everything a nail
and then ddc is really great for
unstructured data but if you're using
spark which is just a code name for huge
structured data then you probably don't
want to version the raw data with dbc
and the use cases that we've seen with
dvc in those cases are for example you
version the query outputs that you're
actually going to train the model on for
posterity but not the entire database
and if i'm using maybe a giant
standardized data set that is never
changing for example imagenet and this
is with the asterisk that imagenet has
changed in the past so uh so this is not
always uh true but if you're using a
standardized data set then it might make
it might make more sense to version only
the models and the process data and not
the um
sort of not the end result
and then finally dvc pipelines are
awesome but they currently don't
natively support distributed workflows
so if that is sort of your core use case
you might want to use a dedicated
solution like
kubeflow pipelines or dagster or one of
those tools uh it is very useful for
sort of storing the information of what
the pipeline looks like in the same
place as your code uh but again if your
core workflow is around distributed
computing then you might want to use
something else
for the pipelining part so you might
still want to use we know a lot of users
that are using kubeflow pipelines and
then dbc to version the results and the
the inputs um but but sort of that is
maybe another proposed use case um so
there was another question
um
yeah
so
so this is uh uh this is a good question
for me because basically so uh mati
basically asks whether or not there is a
diffing solution for dvc track file
because because the the get is sort of
uh um uh
git is only tracking the pointer to the
the file so how do i diff dvc files um
and so
dvc in its native form doesn't really
support that um
uh
sort of as is but that's one of the
added benefits of using dagsa which
again uh if you're going to follow along
the the hands-on session then you're
going to sign up it's completely free um
and if diffing data is important to you
then that's part of the capabilities
that the platform provides on top of dbc
uh same as github on top of git
basically
we'll show also the the capabilities of
diffing that dvc provides which is
basically telling you what has changed
uh when which is also useful but if you
actually want to look at two versions of
images then you're going to use a dag or
something on top of that
and so
the other two questions are is it
possible to vision the data when it is
in the cloud for instance in s3 so the
remote working file system is one
solution for that if dvc has not already
merged this in it's going to be merged
pretty soon enabling you to just add the
data the first time from the cloud as
well so you don't have to copy it
locally in order to add it
but i'm not sure that that's implemented
right now
um and so and then the next step is the
next question from bianca's
recommendation for large tabular data so
there are tools that
are built especially for
versioning large tabular data uh the
examples of that that are open source
are delta lake which is databricks
project uh you have dolt you have uh
terminus to be which i think are all
sort of the the
main players i and i think the
popularity of those are like i said
delta lake dalton and terminus but i
might be mistaken um and the caveat
there is if you want to use those you
need to migrate the schema of your uh
database uh to to one that they support
so that's not always something that
organizations are willing to do and i
think that one point here is to so i'm
going to give a talk next month uh about
sort of how to choose uh which tools to
use i think that one point to notice
here is that maybe you don't need to
version your raw data so if you have a
raw data set that is never going to
change or it's only ad only maybe you
just want to version the subset of that
data that you're actually training your
models in experiments um and so you can
feel free to reach out to me after the
call after the talk and i'd be happy to
help uh uh sort of after i understand
more of your uh the details of your use
case
um and the final question before i'll
move on is why not store and track
everything in um
the pre-processed results that will be
used as input for the model directly in
a database as a timestamp version and
use dbc instead um
so you can basically store things in a
database like a hash table is a form of
data structure right um so it all
depends on what you want out of the box
basically uh the the people the the the
awesome team behind dbc built a lot of
sort of optimizations and capabilities
into the system such as the
native support for cloud storages and
object storages uh that you might want
to use uh such as optimized protocols
for pushing and pulling and
deduplicating data and stuff like that
so it it is sort of arguably more
convenient
but yeah rolling your own is always an
option i personally don't recommend it
but there are some use cases where it
makes sense
so
moving forward
one question that still might remain is
i need a separate tool for data
versioning uh but why
um and this is one of the common
complaints that we've heard uh sort of
like why do i need to learn a whole
separate tool and i can't just use dbc
in addition uh and i need to use it in
addition to using git in order to get
the desired outcome of versioning
everything and sort of having a more
producible project and so some of the
issues uh so this leads to a bunch of
things that dbc is not focused on and
that makes sense because after all it's
more of sort of an infrastructure
oriented project in the same way that
git uh in the same way that git is and
so you might want a higher level api to
deal with things like uh remembering the
order of commands that you want to that
you need to use in order to do something
or deciding if if a given file should be
tracked by git or
dvc and sort of dbc is also very
agnostic which is great for flexibility
but it's sub-optimal for certain
automations and and ease of use and so
that is exactly why we created uh fds or
fast data science let me play this video
as well uh the idea is it combines git
and dbc so that you only need to
type
one command at a time it also has a ton
of automations like a wizard for adding
files that helps you decide whether
files should go
where a file should go um and you can
even do stuff like fds save which
shortens everything like the the ad the
commit and the push and just does it for
you um and so you can uh this should
make your life easier especially if
you're working with a dvc sort of uh
intensively
and you can download it now uh or start
on github that would be appreciated
cool
so um i'll stop sharing for a moment to
share my google collab um oh and by the
way actually before that um
where's the
file that i'm looking for sorry
yeah so you can use this uh
qr code let me make sure that i'm
sharing this screen
you can use this qr code if you like
to go to the url i'll send it send it
also in a moment in the um
in the uh
channel so it does chat rather um so i
am all i'm going to work with this i'm
going to do a bit of live coding which
is always fun um
oh it says that sharing is
stop sorry
okay
so you can all go into this and i'll
start sharing
my screen
okay
so let me know if this uh if you can see
this properly
uh someone just like do the
the thing with the thumb so i know it
works
yes okay
cool
um
so
uh and i'll also take a sip of water so
if you have any questions now would be a
good time and we'll dive into the nitty
gritty
awesome
so everyone understood everything um
so
we are going to
uh go over a bunch of things by the way
i'm going to start by installing all of
this
these packages just because it's going
to take a few minutes um and explain so
basically we're going to do a live
coding session uh for dvc and a bit of
fds uh what we're going to do here is
we're going to build a project from
scratch uh we're going to use dagsa
because again it's the easiest way to
set up a remote so we don't have to mess
around with like cloud settings and and
stuff like that
and and so you can follow along
in order to do that and you can do this
while everything is installing for you
you should sign up for an account on
dagsub and create a repository so these
links will lead you to the exact place
you should uh go to so i already have an
account so i'm just going to click the
create a repository
um and it's going to lead me to this uh
sort of um
this
form and so i'm going to call my project
who moved my data live uh i'll add sort
of a description here uh live
coding for pi data
global um
just leave it like this i'm not going to
change anything else so it's it's public
i didn't touch anything aside from that
and i'll just do create repository um oh
sorry and i didn't delete my old
repository that i practiced with so i'll
do that first
um
[Music]
let me let me go to my profile so nice
this is what you get for live coding
it's going to be fun don't worry
who moved my data live okay so i
practiced this before so let's remove
this i start from scratch
[Music]
okay
so
um
so same thing
uh who moved my data thank god the
browser remembers so live coding
[Music]
and so now we have this empty project
not super interesting a bunch of
commands on how to set things up um and
so
i i coded that into the notebook so we
could just leave it as is for now and go
back to our notebook um if you're
following along i hope that by this
point you have finished installing stuff
and you don't need to restart your
session even though it will tell you you
do
it will actually cause might cause
problems if you restart so just leave it
as is and then let's make sure that um
the
versions have been installed so we can
see this by the way the there's no files
here so just the sample stuff that colab
comes with um and so we're doing a bunch
of imports for the logistics so we can
sort of download data later and and
manage the um
the
uh
the passwords and stuff like that so
let's do that and assuming you signed up
the next step is going to do to be um
sort of uh
writing in your dags of username uh
the repo name and your email and we're
so now you have my email you can uh you
can send me hello um and let's run these
cells just so we have that and this is
basically putting them into an uh sort
of environment variables that we're
going to use later um and then i'm going
to run this step which will require my
token so
um you can get your token by going to
the settings uh panel and then going to
tokens and you can copy your uh
default token that will work you can
also put in your password but i always
recommend working with tokens um where
possible and now we have that as well so
the next step um
yeah sure um so uh lavanya is asking
about if you can do this after the
session you this is going to remain
accessible to everyone uh forever
basically so you can do it whenever you
want um and and you can just follow
along with me if you prefer um
so basically um now i'm going to create
the file structure um and what sorry um
and what i'm going to do here is just
you know making a directory called dvc
showcase it has an internal directory
called data and that is empty and i'm
going to do one last setup thing which
is defining my uh user email and name
for git because colab needs it in order
to push and pull stuff and now we're
going to init git ndbc so this is a
command i didn't cover because it's you
know pretty straightforward but we'll
see what happens and it's going to tell
me that it initialized an empty git
repository and initialized an empty dvc
repository um and now if i run git and
dvc status we're going to see that git
has a bunch of new files added and these
are all um within the dvc
folder so those are basically sort of
logistic files that dbc has created and
then for dbc it's telling us there are
no data or pipelines tracked in this
project yet um and so if we want to
look at what's being get ignored within
the dbc file because we i see that i've
added a dot getting nord file here i can
see that it's ignoring a local
configuration file which makes sense
because that's usually where the
passwords are stored it's ignoring temp
uh and it's ignoring a cache and this
cache is where all the large files are
going to be tracked so it's good that
git is ignoring that
cool
so
now we are going to
create a version a git version with all
of these changes just so we're you know
set to go
um and that's it let's let's dive into
things so we want to download a version
of data so what i'm doing is i'm using
wget and i'm downloading a data set or
maybe let me take a step back and
explain what we're doing here from a
data science perspective so this is
going to be a project where we're taking
data that we extracted from the stack
exchange api uh where there are a ton of
questions that people have asked
and i'll show you when we push this to
the exam i'll show you sort of some of
the data so you understand what i'm
talking about but questions that people
have asked on stack exchange and we are
going to build a model that um predicts
whether or not a question relates to
machine learning and then it can provide
the machine learning tag suggestion to
the user and sort of the logic behind
such a product would be that a question
is more likely to be answered if you add
tags to it and so this can help the user
improve their chances of getting their
question answered
and so we're now downloading a version
of this data
and we want to track it with dbc so you
can see that my data folder now has a
raw.csv file
and let's do dbc add raw.csv so we're
going to see a bunch of things that dbc
is telling me that it's doing uh but
basically uh it's adding this file it's
doing it very quickly because it's
relatively small just like 75 megabytes
but definitely something you don't want
to push into get
and then it even tells me in the end it
says like it's added and it tells me
that if you want to track these changes
you need to run this command which is
very nice of dbc uh but let's review the
things that we discussed earlier so now
we have a raw.csv.evc that has been
created and if we
run this
um we're going to see exactly what we
talked about earlier so we have this md5
we have its size which is 75 megabytes
so it's a bit less than 75 megabytes
and then we have the path to it which is
exactly like we saw before and if i look
at the dvc cache i can see the um again
the same structure that i discussed so
the first two letters are the folder and
the rest of the hash is the file
and that's awesome and if i look at the
db the get ignore i can see that the raw
dv the raw csv is there
okay cool so we have tracked our file
with dbc but this is no no not yet
tracked by git so if i go and i do um
let's say get status and
dvc status as well let's run that and
we'll see that git is saying that data
is still um sort of there is a file
within data that is not tracked um and
those files are actually the raw.csv.dvc
and the dot git ignore because this is
uh get ignored as well um
uh so
arena yes i'll share all of the
materials on slack afterwards i mean you
can continue following along like i
think this is uh you can go over i
showed the link to the notebook and you
can see what i'm doing in real time um
so so feel free to sort of jump in and
and sort of uh work with us
so now let's uh but dvc by the way says
that the data and pipelines are up to
date because from dvc's perspective it
compares the raw.csv.dvc
with what it has in the cache and it
says okay i'm up to date no worries
we're all good so
um
so let's uh um commit this to git and i
named the commit uh adding raw data to
dvc tracking um and now let's change our
data so
i'm actually doing this the reverse of
what happened in real life so i'm now
downloading something that from the name
of the branch you might uh already know
sort of the spoiler is that it's not
good data and what actually happened we
did this project originally was that the
query that we use for stack exchange
wasn't sorted by date so we just got a
random assortment of questions some of
them were like ancient and some of them
were super new and obviously when you
train a model for real life use cases
you probably want the most current data
um and so we got this data version which
is also smaller
and you can see this one is 63 megabytes
the one before was uh i think a bit
larger
yeah so 72 megabytes um so it's also a
different size uh and now that i
downloaded it let's track it so now
there are two ways to track it one is to
do dbc add data raw.csv which is what
we're going to do but you can also do
dvc commit and then as an input give it
a dbc stage so that works both for
adding so i would do raw.csv.c but also
for pipelines um and i'll discuss that
maybe a bit later so let's run this
and dbc is basically going to do exactly
the same thing um that it did
before um and so we it is now going to
tell us i don't need to now recommit
some of the files but for example the
getting or is still ignoring the same
file uh but the data.raw.csv.dc
has changed and so let's look inside and
what we can see is that the hash here
and the size are different from before
so just to remind you before it started
with a
14 and now it's starting the hash is
starting with the 70.
and when we look inside the cache we're
actually going to see that now there's
another sort of entry in our hash table
um one of them is a sort of uh the old
one and this is a new one and when we
look at the project so you can see this
also here it's basically the same like
this is it's sort of like magic right
the raw.csv has been changed but we have
both version versions in our cache so if
i want to go back to that old version i
could just do git reset minus minus hard
head because i didn't commit anything to
get yet um and then when i can when i
look inside the
dvc file i can see that i reverted to
the old version
but notice that what's happening now if
i do get status on dbc status git is
going to say
everything is okay like there's nothing
changed right because i reset to the
last commit but dvc is going to say wait
you reverted the git files but not the
dvc files so it's going to tell me that
there's a changed output for the
raw.csv.dc file which is data raw dot
csv and that makes total sense so in
order to sort of synchronize the project
i'm going to do dbc checkout and now dbc
is swapping the files
so i have the
original file that i want and if i do
status again it's going to tell me that
life is good
cool so we have our first version
tracked i know you're all excited let's
push this to remote so now we're going
to run all the commands that i showed
earlier in the slides to set up the
remote this one is to set up git this
one is to set up dbc and notice that
we're using our placeholders so if you
did the first part of like putting in
the name of your user and and your
project it's going to be set up for you
out of the box and then we're doing the
um
sort of authentication setup
which is basically going to be we're
using the minus minus local flag which
means dvc is going to make all of these
modifications to the um to the
uh dvc
config.local which is not going to push
to dvc so you can't take my um
my password um and now if we're looking
inside the config file we're going to
see that there's sort of a remote origin
defined which is the name i called my
dvc remote and that url is dagsob.com
d slash removed my data live dot dvc so
similar to
the the remote you'd have on github for
git which ends with a get here it's
ending with a dot dvc
so now let's do git status
and it's going to tell us that dvc
config has changed
by the way dbc status is not changing
anything right because we haven't
modified any of the dvc tracked files so
data and pipelines are up to date and
now let's commit this to git
so we're adding this to ubc remote and
let's do push and a node here is because
this is google colab they have an issue
with authentication so you can't just
push to the
origin without adding the token into the
url it's kind of annoying
but it's sort of a necessary evil
so you just need to do this and it will
work you can also copy this for the
future and just modify the urls uh so
the url for your project if you if
you're using something which is not
within this rel and so what dvc is doing
now is it basically pushed the 72
megabyte file which is it and it only
pushes that even though my local
workspace has another file because there
are no git commits that refer to that
file that is not being pushed okay
that's an important note to take and now
i'm going to use this nifty ipython
display function to show you how my dags
of project looks like
at the moment so you can see sorry
you can see basically this file
structure
that is basically the file structure
that you can also see here within the
data i'm also showing the the hidden
files which are dbc and deepsegnor and
you can see this very basic pipeline
which is just like adding a raw.csv file
but the nice thing is i can actually
scroll to the data file itself so this
is a file that is not tracked by d by
git is tracked by dbc you can see this
is part of the ui so if you wanted to
see earlier what's the data like what
are the samples that i'm actually
looking at sorry this is because it's an
iframe um you can actually see that each
row here is a question on stack exchange
you can see the name accepting uh null
hypothesis giving specificity uh there's
body there's a few tags so that's pretty
um
it's pretty useful uh and then there's a
bunch of metadata on this uh data as
well
but let's get back to things okay so we
now have our first version tracked
and let's build a pipeline
uh um
so okay i see that irwin has an issue
with ipines iphone is not defined make
sure that you run the import cell at the
beginning where we're doing import
ipython here um so that that should work
after that and if not then reach out to
me afterwards and i'll try to debug it
with you um but this sort of runs end to
end so if you're running each step one
after the other and you created the
project on dags hub then it should just
work for you um
okay so where were we
we pushed the first version now let's
start with running stuff so we'll need
to download a script which i prepared in
advance um so we're not doing that that
level of uh of live coding uh i ran this
so now our project is going to have a
preprocess.pi file i can open that um
and sort of you can see it's pretty
straightforward i'm doing a bunch of
like house cleaning so changing the
format of the date uh creating a
sort of uh
an output or label basically column
using the um
sort of a machine learning tag here so
i'm checking whether or not the tags
contain machine learning and then i'm
labeling this as true for the machine
learning tag um
and i'm also making sure to remove the
tag so it's not it doesn't use the input
to predict the
sort of the output and doesn't cheat um
and that's basically it you can dive
into this later if you want um but but
but yeah this is i'll move this
i'll close this uh so let's go back to
where i was
um
so now i'm going to run the same the
similar command to what you saw before
so the dependencies are the raw data the
uh
the code that sort of runs the
pre-processing then the output is going
to be two files one is train and one is
test data and then i'm going to call
this step pre-processing and i'm going
to run the command python3 preprocess.pi
which does all of this magic so let's
run this
and this is a relatively fast step um
[Music]
so let's see what happens in our file
structure
basically uh okay awesome so it's done
so basically now let's refresh this you
can see that
our data file our data folder also has a
test.csv and a train.csv notice that it
does not have a raw.cs or it doesn't
have like a test.csv.dbc
because it is managed as part of the
pipeline uh and then we have a ddc.lock
and a dbc.yaml so let's look inside
those uh the dvc yaml is basically what
we saw similar to what we saw before it
has the name of the stage it has the
command that we're going to run um and
it has the dependencies and outputs
um
do you use the cis args within your
python
modules so that dbc can run the pipeline
i'm not sure i understand the question
but dvc is basically agnostic to um
how you what you run and how you run it
so the script is in charge of receiving
parameters and processing the data or
training the model and then outputting
the outputs and what dbc checks is that
the inputs that you define here exist
before the model is run that the outputs
that you define exist after the stages
run
and so it's your responsibility you can
do it however you want which is again
very flexible but sometimes it means
that you need to do a bit of a work up
front to get everything uh ready to go
and so back to what we've created let's
look at the dbc dot lock again very
similar struct sorry very similar
structure to the dvc ammo but we also
have our md5s um
we also have our md5s and the sizes of
our
files here um and this is the same for
the outputs so the test.csv
this is basically equivalent to what we
saw before in the dot csv dvc file but
we have this also for the outputs and
this is what bbc is going to use to
manage these versions
so now let's do uh git status on the dbc
status it'll take this
opportunity to take a simple letter
okay
so what we can see here is that
we have a modified git ignore file which
makes sense because what we added to it
are the outputs of this file we have a
dvc lock and dvc ammo that we're added
we have the preprocess.pi which we
downloaded
downloaded before
um
yeah okay i see now with
um
exactly so you can hard code it which i
did for the sake of simplicity it is not
a good idea in in the longer run in the
long run what we recommend to do is to
have a parameters.yaml file and then
have the dvc script read those
parameters and use them that is a more
sort of robust way um to manage your
your project and configuration in a in a
sane way without having someone have to
to read your entire code base but
because this is a very simple project in
the demo i i thought it would be easier
than adding a bunch of dependencies
um okay so now we're going to do a bunch
of commands which are basically
the data by the way the dvc status is
that everything is up to date because
again dbc compares the files that it
sees in your workspace with the dbc log
or the dbc files and it sees that
they're all they all correspond well to
each other and so it's not complaining
about anything and so we only need to
get add and commit
our changes but not to dvc add or commit
anything
um and now let's um let's do that and
then also let's push this to our remote
so this is basically the same commands
that i ran before it's going to take a
few more seconds because there are it's
a bit larger now that i process the data
um but that's it basically so you can
see that it basically performs the same
action as before and let's do the same
thing and look what we have at dax up
so
we have the same project uh but it's now
sorry i don't know it scrolls to the
bottom uh it has a it has a bit more
file so you can see the preprocess.pi
here and then the data folder is uh also
sort of uh including the test and and
trained data uh but also our pipeline if
we remember from earlier this should
look a bit similar to what you saw in
the um
in the presentation so you can see that
i have my raw csv and the pre-processed
uh code that are going into the
pre-processed step by the way if i
expand this you can see the command that
i was actually running and then the
outputs are the test and the train uh
csv and that's
that's awesome so we are good to go
um so let's go to the next step and
let's create a training a training
script and a training stage for our
pipeline so we're going to do this in a
different way than what we did before
but first and foremost let's download um
let's download our training script so if
i refresh this we now have a train dot
pi this is going to use both the train
set and the test set and it's going to
do all in one so it's going to train the
model and evaluate it and the output is
going to be the model plus a test metric
dot csv which is going to or sorry it's
going to be both tests and train metrics
in one csv and it's going to tell us
sort of uh how the model performed and
this time we're going to create this
step in a different way so i i i created
this i wrote this code down and let's
just i'll double click it just so it's
preserves the indent and let's copy this
and put this in our dvc.yaml so you can
also edit the dvcml directly um
and i'll just paste this here
and the thing you should notice here is
the indent so make sure that it's not
all to the left or something like that
the the end is important so you have the
name of the stage then it's indented
once you have the command the
dependencies the list the output's a
list and in this case our parameters
which are in output um are not are
tracked by git not dbc so that's why
they have cache false and then we have
metrics which have special treatment and
those metrics are also tracked by git so
they also have cache false
so let's save this
okay it's already saved and we can close
this and let's go back to where i was in
my um
in my process so we we updated this and
if i look at my dbc ammo i now will see
the updates which is good um but if i go
to get status and dbc status dbc is now
so git is going to complain that the dbc
ammo has been modified and i added the
train.pi but dbc is also complaining why
because it is looking for these outputs
that i defined in my uh in my process uh
by dvc ammo and it's not finding them um
and it's also looking at the train and
test.csv and it sees that it doesn't has
ha doesn't have hashes for them um
because in my dvc lock file
basically i don't have the dependencies
uh or the outputs for the next stage so
dvc if it lacks the
hashes in the dvc lock it says that
something has changed
so now if we want to run this we can do
dvc repro and dvc is going to see
that the pre-processing step has already
been run so it's going to tell me stage
preprocessing didn't change i'm skipping
this also the the
raw.csv.ebc stage hasn't changed so i'm
skipping this and now it's going to
train the model um
and
and uh let's wait a bit but it's
basically using tfidf and then a random
force classifier so a very basic model
um and
i think
the the nice thing is i'm probably going
to make it on time which is awesome uh
but if you have any questions so far uh
this would be a good time while the
models is training
uh anything else that you feel i didn't
uh cover
awesome so
as a side note i will be available both
on slack and the gather town afterwards
so if you have any questions you feel
free to reach out to me
and i'll be happy to help um
so now it's saving the tf idf which we
fitted and it's now training the model
and this shouldn't take too long uh we
can go back to the folder structure by
the way so by the way to log the metrics
and the
parameters we're using a library which
we created which is super simple it's
called dag so you can do pip install
dags up again open source and what it
does is basically logs the metrics and
the parameters to files so these are
human readable you can open them check
them out yourself
um and and we like that because it makes
it easier to share you don't need
context in order to understand what's
going on i'll show you the contents in a
moment
um
so
manuel is asking why is the pi script
itself a dependency and so what the way
you need to think about this is when do
we want dbc to run this uh stage again
so obviously if the data has changed we
want this step to rerun again but also
if we change the code so maybe you
change the code you're using a different
model then you want dbc to run that
training step again because the results
are going to be different um and so the
the way we think about dependencies is
we want to define the things that for
this stage if they have changed we want
to re-run that stage okay so it's it's
finished running
uh perfect timing um
and yeah i'll show uh uh i'll show uh um
fts in just a moment uh but the answer
is yes
um so the parameter is just so you can
see uh what we've created um look like
this it's just a list of parameters uh
both for the tf idf and the model as
well as the metrics are also a very
simple uh table that you can see so the
name the value and when when these uh
metrics were logged
again this is a very simple model so
everything here is simple but you can
log more complex uh metrics as well
um cool so what did we get out of all of
this um
all of this thing so now that it's run
um let's go here
so basically let's look at the get
status and dvc status that we have
basically now dbc is saying data and
pipelines are up to date yay it's done
successful and git is saying that dvc
lock and yaml have changed which may
make sense because i uh modified the dvc
ammo manually and then the lock was
changed after the reproduce of the dvc
repro and then git ignore we have a
model now um
in it and then metrics parameters and
the train which we added
but
if you have noticed and ilia has noticed
because he asked about this we ran a ton
of duplicate commands throughout this
tutorial um so what if you wanted to
unify everything
fts provides that so i
pre-installed fds in the beginning
and we can actually now do fds status
and it will basically do the same thing
as the command before it prints it in a
meter way so it's clear to see what dbc
is saying and what git is saying as
opposed to here
and it is also
uh just to make a point of how
useful this is you can commit all the
changes and push them to your remote
with one command for both dbc and git
and you can do this by running db fds
commit and then fds push
but if we want to make it even shorter
we can use fds save and fds save is
basically a short for
add everything commit everything and
push everything to the remote um and
that is very convenient so just to
clarify what i'm using here uh we have
fds save and then this flag means this
is the get remote and the reason i need
to specify it specifically is because of
the collab issue so if you're working
locally you don't need to do this apart
if you set up your get remote fds nose
and then also we're going to add a
message a save message so in this case
adding the training step and this fds ad
is actually interactive so if i go back
to what i said before it is now going to
look at the different files and it's
going to ask me what i want to do with
them so it sees that i have a data
folder here with 220 megabytes um and
it's asking me should i add the entire
folder to dvc but i know that uh i don't
need to because uh it has been added if
like the contents have been added so i'm
just going to type in s which is going
to tell it to step into that and then
it's going to realize that itself um and
that's it so you can now see that it's
uh it added everything successfully both
to get a dbc it committed everything to
get and now it's pushing everything uh
both to get and and dvc and it tells me
in the end i successfully saved your
current workspace and let's see that it
make sure that it works um
so let's uh see how my updated project
looks like um and so now what we see
automatically is the train dot pi has
been added as well as the metrics that
csun the params and look at this super
nice pipeline that we have
uh again the pre-processing step is
basically not changed but the test csv
train dot csv and train.pi are now going
into the training step and the outputs
of those are in the outputs folder so
i'll show you those in the middle but in
a moment you can actually go to them
from the pipeline itself
so it now opens it in a new window but
you can see that i saved the model and
the tfidf uh tokenizer um
and um
and so that's super nice and you can
even see the metrics for your model
within this pipeline as well so that's
also pretty cool and also because we're
using this very standard format for
metrics and parameters you can also see
uh we have this experiments tab um
which is
sorry let's let it load
uh you we have this experiments tab in
every project you can actually see this
experiment logged as part of a
of a table so you can see the different
metrics and parameters you can actually
play with this so modify the metrics and
parameters that you have um and then
dive into a specific experiment
and see how it performs um and so that's
also uh pretty useful
and that is it so i have four minutes
i'm i'm i'm pretty proud of myself for
making it in time um is thank you very
much for sort of joining along uh for
this journey with me um and if you want
any further reading so the first link
here is for data uh registries uh using
dbc it's really nice uh one of our team
members wrote it and i and it's like not
necessarily tied to dags of it's really
awesome the other one is an example of
automating sort of creating continuous
training uh with jenkins in dags of
using dvc um and then the other the last
one is one uh explaining fds in more
detail and again please follow me on
twitter or linkedin and join our discord
community um you have links to all of
those on the uh notebook as well um
let's see if there are any other
questions
so
um
so matit asks about
minus the option to dvc runs really
prone to human errors uh
the short answer is
probably we recommend editing the dbc
ammo directly as opposed to doing dbc
run i agree with you it's prone to
errors the way i would do this before
sort of the dbc ammo was uh easy to to
use as it is today was i would write
this in like uh uh i would write the
commands in scripts make sure in like a
text file make sure that everything is
is good and then only then copy this and
run this into uh the the command line so
definitely recommend i i prefer to edit
the dvc ammo um instead um martine asks
if there's a way to self-host dagsub
please feel free to reach the answer is
yes feel free to reach out to me and and
we can discuss this um so
jamie is asking about the lock file so i
indeed covered this you can see the
contents uh here above but basically
what it has is the
same as dvc ammo but for each file it
tells you what is the unique version of
that file in the current workspace and
the dbc uses this to check what has
changed um
uh
what should we respond to the question
add to dvc so the answer is s which is
step into um unfortunately uh um colab
doesn't support command line tools very
well uh so you if you press h it will it
will just cancel the h which is help
which usually should tell you what the
options are it will instead fail um so
you should do s in this case and i
recommend experimenting with fds locally
first
is this like poetry i'm not sure i
understand the question you can use dbc
to uh
to manage large files um so maybe in
that sense it's like poetry because
poetry manage manages packages but dbc
is very optimized for data science data
set and model management so in that
sense it's not so close to poetry uh is
there a way to connect with ml
experimentation uh tracking
so
like weights and vices so the answer is
it is very versatile depending on how
you define connect so you can use dvc
and weights and biases in parallel we
have uh users that are using dags of
with weights and devices you can
definitely log experiments there and log
your data to like dags over some other
remote but there's no built-in
integration between uh weights and vices
and and dvc uh at least not currently uh
we might build that later um
so matthias is asking
uh where can we get the notebook so i'll
send the link again um
let me this will scroll you to the end
probably maybe let me go to the top
uh
but yeah so
this is the notebook feel free to use it
i'll share it also in the in the slack
and i'll add it to the description of
the talk uh so everyone has it um
any questions by the way someone wants
to go on and ask in person
um
came for the tutorial stay for the
halloween cats yes if you have not are
not familiar with this uh go to the
google collab settings and then go to
miscellaneous and then you have the
corgi mode in the kitty mode very
recommended and now they are in
halloween costumes because why not um
and the power level as well i'm not
doing this you can check it out for
yourself
um
so thank you everyone for joining it was
a pleasure uh to give this uh talk and
sort of join you today uh please feel
free to reach out to me i will be on the
slack
at
my name and as well as in gather town
with my name as well
and have a great day everyone